it's over 1100 degrees in there each
roof tile in this gas-fired Kiln needs
to be heated for 48 hours making tiles
is energy intensive which is why this
Factory in the West Midlands could be
the kind of business forced to pause if
there's a national shortage of gas that
they say would have serious consequences
we're extremely worried
we have extortion of gas prices we're
struggling to survive as it is if we
have to stop in an emergency gas
balancing alert then we have potentially
half a million roof tiles 250 000 bricks
work in progress that could be lost
traffic for us
if it goes on any longer than 24 hours
we're going to have to start looking at
laying off stuff
it's a worst case scenario they could be
facing within months the energy
regulator of germ has warned the UK
faces a significant risk of gas
shortages this winter due to the impact
of Russia's war in Ukraine
supplies of gas from Russia to Europe
have been drastically cut and reduced
further by the Damage Done to the
nordstream pipelines in the Baltic Sea
the fear now is whether the UK will be
able to import enough from Europe
Britain can rely on around 2.5 billion
cubic meters of gas it has in store on a
peak Winter's day we use around 350
million cubic meters so the stored
energy would last about seven days
usually we can also access almost 100
million cubic meters a day from Europe
but that's now in doubt a gas supply
emergency would prompt fears of
blackouts but experts say household
supplies would be prioritized
in the extreme hypothetical situation
where an emergency takes place the
residential gas supply and then Supply
to uh in here
public utilities and public services are
always the last last thing to be cut we
have uh Power stations in Britain
consume loads of gas
um
so they would be the biggest chunks to
be removed in any in any sort of
rationing scenario
but cutting off gas-fired power plants
would create another problem industry
rules mean the plant owners would face
big Financial penalties for failing to
supply electricity the risk of that
happening could force generators to
reduce Advanced sales pushing up the
price of electricity even more Becky
Johnson Sky News